is there any
data on what intelligent means for
success in life
success in life there is a
tremendous amount of validity data
that looked at
intelligence test scores
and
various measures of
life success
now of course life success is a pretty
broad
topic
and not everybody agrees on
you know what success means but there's
general agreement on certain aspects of
success
that can be measured
uh
and uh including life expectancy like
you said life expectancy now there's
life success uh
you know uh life expectancy uh
i mean though
that is such an interesting finding but
it you know iq scores are also
correlated to things like income
now okay so who thinks
income
means you're successful that's not the
point the point is that income is one
empirical measure
in this culture
that says something about your level of
success now you can define success in
ways that have nothing to do with income
you can define success
based on your evolutionary natural
selection
success
you know you but for variables
uh yeah and even that by the way is
correlated to iq in in some uh studies
so
however you want to define success
iq is important
it's not the only determinant people get
hung up on well what about personality
what about so-called emotional
intelligence yes all those things matter
the thing that matters
empirically the single thing that
matters the most is your general
ability your general mental intellectual
ability your reasoning ability and the
more complex your vocation
the more complex your job the more g
matters
g doesn't matter in a lot of occupations
don't require complex thinking
and there are occupations like that and
g doesn't matter within an occupation
the
g might not matter so much
so that if you look at
all the professors at mit
and had a way to rank order them on you
know
there's a ceiling effect is what i'm
saying
that you know
also when you get past a certain
threshold then there's impact on wealth
for example or career success
however that's defined in each
individual discipline but
after a certain point it doesn't matter
actually it does matter in certain
things so for example there is a very
classic study
that was started at johns hopkins when i
was a graduate student there i actually
worked on this study at the very
beginnings the study of mathematically
and scientifically precocious youth and
they gave
junior high school students age
11 and 12
the
standard s.a.t math exam
and they found a very large number of
students
scored very high on this exam
not a large number i mean they they
found many students when they cast the
net to all of baltimore they found a
number of students who scored as high on
the s.a.t math when they were 12 years
old as incoming hopkins freshmen
and they said gee now this is
interesting
what shall
we do now
and uh on a case-by-case basis they got
some of those kids into their local
community college math programs
uh
many of those kids went on to be very
successful
and now there's a 50-year follow-up of
those kids
and it turns out
if
these kids were in the top one percent
okay so everybody in this study is in
the top one percent if you take that
group
that rarefied group and divide them into
quartiles
so that you have the top 25 percent of
the top one percent and the bottom 25
percent
of the top one percent you can find
on measurable
variables of success
the top quartile does better than the
bottom quartile in the top one percent
they have more patents they have more
publications they have more tenure at
universities and this is based on
their you're dividing them based on
their score at age 12.
i wonder how much interesting
data is in the variability in the
differences so but that that's really
that that's
oh boy that's very interesting but it's
also
i don't know somehow painful i don't
know why it's so painful
that that's so that g factor so
determinant
of even at in the nuanced
topic it's interesting that you find
that painful do you find it painful that
people with charisma
are very successful can be very
successful in life even though having no
other attributes other than they're
they're famous and people like them do
you feel that painful
yes if that charisma is untrainable
so one of the things again this is like
i learned psychology from the johnny
depp trial
but
one of the things the psychologist the
personality psychologist he could maybe
speak to this because he had interest
in this for time
is uh she was saying that personality
technically speaking is the thing that
doesn't change
over a lifetime it's the it's the thing
you're i don't know if she was actually
implying that you're born with it well
it's a trait it's a trait it's a
straight that's relatively stable over
time that i think that's generally
correct so to the degree your
is stable over time
yes that too
is painful
because what's not painful is the thing
you know
if i'm fat and out of shape i can
exercise
and you know uh become healthier in that
way if my
diet is a giant mess
and that's resulting in some kind of
conditions that my body is experiencing
i can fix that by having a better diet
that sort of my actions
my willed actions can make a change
if charisma is part of the personality
that's
the part of the charisma that is part of
the personality that is stable
yeah yeah that's painful too because
it's like oh [ __ ] i'm stuck with this
i'm stuck with this
well i mean and this pretty much
generalizes to every aspect of your
being this is who you are you to deal
with it and what it undermines of course
is a realistic appreciation for this
undermines
the fairly recent
idea
prevalent in this country that if you
work hard you can be anything you want
to be
which has morphed from the original idea
that if you work hard you can be
successful
those are two different things
yeah
and now we have
if you work hard you can be anything you
want to be
this is completely unrealistic i'm sorry
it just is now you can work hard and be
successful there's no question
but you know what the heart i could work
very hard and i am not going to be a
successful
uh theoretical physicist i'm just not
that said i mean we should
because we had this conversation already
but it's good to repeat
the fact that you're not going to be a
theoretical physicist
is not judgment on your basic humanity
returning again to the all men
which means men and women are created
equal
so again some of the differences we're
talking about in quote-unquote success
wealth
uh
number of uh whether you win a nobel
prize or not that doesn't um
put a measure on your basic humanity and
the
basic value
and even goodness of you as a human
being
because that
your basic role and value in society is
largely
within your control
uh it's it's some of these measures that
we're talking about
uh it's good it's good to remember this
you